winning live pop sensation Meghan
Trainor is Our Guest
S
I know and co-hosting for the whole day
I'm here all day never leave never leave
don't even get me started I know well
you know what let's start with the news
Megan take it away oh God this is me I
love how cute
I had to get my glasses on first up
Queen of All Things Adele she's singing
her heart out in Las Vegas but what is
she wearing she could have her Gucci on
she could wear her Louis Vuitton
even with no shoes on Adele made you
look that's right apparently Adele is
singing in her socks The Daily Mail
report she's pairing her Versace dress
with gripping slipper socks and I love
it I mean I love that she's doing this I
love that she knows what she needs yes
okay I feel like I
said oh what's Rossi's take on it listen
I Love Adele but I mean girl you can set
fire to the rain but you can't put shoes
on please come on
right no wonder she wrote she no wonder
she wrote easy on me so I wouldn't
really go there when I found her she
wore grippy socks maybe the socks are
the easy on me I don't know I listen and
Fidel wants to wear her grippy socks
then I guess you know you just go with
it Megan Have you ever worn something on
stage like what's the wildest thing
you've ever worn on stage
a thumb
I know and it was such a hot picture
that they can't even show it on the show
today
scandalous it was her um it was for
Pride for La Pride I performed in like a
onesie and my butt cheeks were out yes
and my dad was like well you're brave
and I was like I look so good yeah did
you feel good yeah that crowd was the
best crowd ever and they were just fun
for me and I was like you love me yeah
if you're gonna wear a thong do it at
Pride yeah
I ever wear them all right next up
breaking news for all my single friends
who make up 50 of the population
according to the census interesting 50 I
know I did not think the number would be
that high
anyway Apartment Therapy reports a new
study examined 36 metrics to find the
best city for singles in America they
looked at everything from sheer density
of singles to the balance of men to
women to the cost of a dinner date for
two and the results are in if you want
to find love head to drum roll please
Seattle Washington oh my people
my single people oh my God are you guys
from Seattle
yeah well uh apparently Tom Hanks and
Meg Ryan weren't wrong right right um
yeah and uh where there's a best
unfortunately there is a worst I'm so
sorry to Warwick Rhode Island
Megan you have someone here that's
single and ready to mingle yes
a single stallion if you will my great
my older brother Ryan Trader
you're single huh yeah yeah and he's
about to turn 30. what do you like best
about being single
um freedom
Freedom yes yeah no responsibilities I
could do whatever I want
um
but then again it's like it's nice to
watch I'd like to have someone to watch
White Lotus with you totally yeah yeah
good job
um it's the best show so are you single
by choice or are you actively looking
I just recently got back into the dating
scene sobered up like a year and a half
ago so that was a big change for me
[Applause]
so you're like is a wing woman when will
yeah wing wing women I've always wanted
a sister so I have two brothers and
they're like just newly dating uh right
now and I'm just ready for my sister oh
my God you're like you are the best like
Matchmaker and wingman it's so true and
Chris Olson's also single
[Applause]
on the show
we did a whole gaming segment with him
yeah dating segment with Chris how did
that go how did it go it went well I
feel very optimistic about possibilities
yes so let's work on it all so long I am
yeah but first finally we need to settle
this holiday debate once and for all
Forbes Magazine asked this question if
you get someone a gift card is that a
lame gift or a pretty cool gift what do
you guys think
all I did for Christmas
oh my no the Young Generation all they
want is money yes they don't want me to
pick my little cousins in college they
don't want me to pick out the jacket
they want me to get the money for the
jacket are you that old now that you can
be like you know what the kids want the
kids want this well my mom too I have an
eight-year-old cousin and she's like
money money all I want is money and I'm
like oh my God it's like the new
generation that's what they want
speaking of the perfect holiday gifts
I've got two right here that's right
it's Megan's brand new album
[Applause]
so run out and buy them I love you
unless you're in the audience because
you're taking them both home today
after the break
it is our great honor to have a true
hero in our midst Rich Fiera one of the
people who left into action to stop the
shooter in Colorado Springs is here
today to share his story I'm very
honored that he would be here we'll be
right back thank you
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign